and minimus
[Laughter]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists yeah welcome to episode
137 today we're gonna talk about goals
and direction actually I know what we're
gonna call this one either goals or
direction I think what will we'll find
out after this conversation right yeah
probably if you're watching this on
YouTube we just launched the the YouTube
version of the podcast last week we have
our first YouTube gasps sees a repeat
gasps ladies and gentlemen TK Coleman is
in the building all right TK thank you
for being here we we wanted to drag you
back into the studio because you are
you're leaving Los Angeles soon leaving
Los Angeles like we were just becoming
friends and then as soon as I get a
friend they move away I'm taking my
talents to South Carolina that's right
so let's talk about that why are you
going to South Carolina and I think your
shirt says it mostly yeah yeah the
answer is in the shirt man so the Praxis
headquarters have have always been in
Charleston from the beginning although
we are a program where participants live
and you know all throughout the US we
have business partners all throughout
the US but the team is getting together
man we've all been working remotely
building this thing for the last about
five years but now it's time to take
everything to the next level raise the
quality of service that we provide to
our participants and yeah just really
ramp everything up and really change the
education game like we've been trying to
so it's time to be physically together
as a team with all the technology we
have it's easy to communicate with each
other from long distances but man
there's nothing like being in the same
city with your team I not then like it
at all I know man like Josh and I being
in LA together I mean could you imagine
if I was if I stayed behind in Montana
no and we were trying to work everything
out it would be it would be crazy and
and also the same the same is true like
we don't do any like traditional
interviews on the podcast at all right
but whenever we bring someone in it has
to be in person right you just don't get
the same thing from talking over Skype I
mean you can you can solve problems over
the phone you can solve problems from
miles away but there you can't replace
this sort of in-person interactions
real quick TK before we dive into
today's questions give us a 30-second
overview of what praxis is and you're
leaving Los Angeles to go to South
Carolina praxis
what's what's the the elevator pitch on
on praxis it is a one-year boot camp and
apprenticeship that helps people launch
their careers without college and so so
it really helps people who who are maybe
stuck on well what their goal should be
or maybe they've been handed goals by
society I'm supposed to do this
four-year thing which is called college
or maybe it's five years or maybe it's
eight years maybe it's forever and in
some people's cases or maybe some people
are like well I know I don't want to go
that route but I'm not sure what I want
to do you help people sort of navigate
the waters of of finding their curiosity
finding a career and then and then
moving on in a meaningful direction
absolutely we believe one of the best
ways to discover things about yourself
is through immersion in the creative
process right like we tend to limit
ourselves to introspection and nasal
gaming navel-gazing but you got to
engage reality and you got to get
feedback from the real world by doing
things so we place people at an
apprenticeship where they work for six
months and they do that after graduating
the professional boot camp for six
months so there's a lot of opportunity
through a combination of professional
development projects and real work with
real customers real projects and so
forth to uh to kind of develop that
self-knowledge
but it's not limited to that there are
also people who come into the program
saying I know I want to work in
marketing I know I want to work in sales
I know I want to do tech I know I want
to do operations and we have
opportunities and training for those
people as well yes so I'm gonna put you
on the spot a little bit you have like
give our audience like a like your
favorite success story
well practice practice man like a
student who came in they you know they
went through this year program and you
know you really got them where they
wanted to be yeah oh my gosh that there
are so many but I'll give Lydia Hodgson
she's someone that I just saw at feek on
a conference that we just did this past
weekend and to your point about the
difference of seeing people in person I
work with these participants you know
doing zoom session Skype sessions
I can Facebook and so forth but there is
nothing like being around them there's
nothing like the informal unplanned
conversations that emerge and the sorts
of things you find out about people in
that context but one of the beautiful
things about her story is before doing
the program she had spent roughly about
six months just kind of backpacking and
traveling through Europe and just sort
of doing some soul-searching and she got
all that she could get out of that
process and said I know that I need to
do something more than this this this
traveling soul-searching thing is only
gonna take me so far and right around
that time she heard about praxis and she
didn't know what she wanted to do for a
career she didn't know what her dream
job was and she applied for the program
she was accepted and a rockstar
participant throughout the program and
she was placed at one of our business
partners in Pittsburgh go Realty and she
moved there to a new city she didn't
know anything about she was scared of
that am I gonna like this place I'm
living in I know nothing about real
estate and I'm not so sure if this is my
passion but I need some experience I
want to learn and she she just worked
with a really great team who really
loved her and she was placed in a
position where she was given a lot of
trust and a lot of responsibility very
early on there were challenges that came
up and they just gave her the keys and
they said hey we trust what you can do
with it and we trusted your ability to
learn from it let's see what happens and
and she's grown tremendously from that
experience and recently they contacted
us and they said hey can we clone her
you know is there a way that we can just
make sure like we clone her so that we
can just have more and more and more but
they told us hey we want to accept more
participants in the program because we
really like the value that she brings in
the mindset my set that she brings and
to this day she's still not 100% sure
that this is what she wants to do for
the rest of her life but she's learning
some valuable skills she's she's
creating value for others and just
discovering a lot of awesome things
about life so that's one of my favorite
that's awesome and no share limit yeah I
I think sometimes what we we actually
get this can we get this concept in our
mind like what am I supposed to do for
the rest of my life as though there is
an ant is so much pressure man put on to
put on ourselves and we're just and
that's literally what we're doing is
we're putting that pressure
so I'm not going around saying I wonder
what TK should do for the rest of his
life right no one's actually thinking
that about you and they're okay if you
decide I wanted to shift paths and even
if it's scary for them that you're
making some sort of change I member when
I walked away from the corporate world I
felt like people were more scared for me
than I was for myself as though there
was something wrong wrong with me
because they were like oh my god
and I was projecting their own fear too
right right and I realized I had already
gone through my own process of of that
fear there cepting and realizing what
what what where my journey was taking me
even though I didn't have what am I
gonna do for the rest of my life I had
what was this next step for me and and
that was helpful I think really what
you're talking about here with praxis or
some of the stuff we'll talk about today
is discovering what that next step is it
doesn't have to be the grandiose thing
what am I gonna do when I'm 80 years old
although I can that can be helpful what
am I gonna say when I look back at a
teacher and am I happy with how I spent
this time here maybe that's a better way
to look at it then can I do this one
thing for the next 60 years of my life
Josh please please please I beg you
yeah yeah I think so I want to speak to
this what I got to do for the rest of my
life yeah I I do too I was I was gonna
stop talking cuz we should get on with
the show
okay so I have a theory on where this
comes from so whenever we make decisions
there are two elements involved too when
we evaluate risk the first is what's the
probability that I'll get it right okay
and then the second is you know what are
the cost of being wrong okay so if I'm
deciding on something like what school
am I gonna go to or what car I'm going
to buy or what I'm gonna eat for lunch
the first is the probability of getting
it right like what are the odds that
I'll be happy with the choice I make and
that's a big factor but the factor that
produces the most anxiety is the cost of
being wrong whenever there's a low cost
of being wrong we're not all that
freaked out about the odds so when when
someone is deciding on what they want
for dinner or if they're buying a
toaster people don't freak out about
these things they tend to be very risky
and very experimental because there's a
low cost of being wrong if I get it
wrong if I buy some cereal or a loaf of
bread I don't
like I can always just go back and you
replace it right but whenever the cost
of being wrong is really high well you
better get it right right because
because there's just a huge loss so we
worry more when we're doing things like
buying a house or buying a car or when
we're choosing to get married because
the cost of being wrong is really high
the traditional approach to education
has artificially driven up the cost of
getting it wrong because for the average
person that's 18 years old what's the
cost of making the wrong decision about
what you want to do with your life well
the cost is four five six years of your
life and anywhere from seventy to a
hundred thousand dollars that's a pretty
high cost so if you decide I like
teaching and you go to school and you
major in elementary education five six
years later you go out into the real
world and after a year of that you
decide you don't like kids well that's a
lot of time and a lot of money you just
invested into making that choice so it
puts a lot of pressure on young people
to make sure they think really hard
about it and get it right and that's
artificial because nature already has a
built-in mechanism for us to discover
what we like and what we want to do and
that's called experience that's called
experimentation and the cost of that is
actually relatively low and what we have
to do is return to a way of educating
young people that reduces the cost of
experimentation so they can discover
things in the way that human beings were
designed to discover through
experimentation yes like what you're
talking about is building in these these
experiments that don't have the maybe
they have some calls to put but the
benefit of that cost is almost always
going to outweigh what the actual cost
is even even in failure we learned so
much yes oh so you and I have been going
back forth and text about every second
da finals and you know LeBron James loss
what is he three and six no three and
five some I don't know six okay three I
know it okay
that means he's now lost as many finals
as Michael Jordan is one
counting though and I and I sent you
this thing that John Mayer posted he
said you should look at this LeBron
James thing as a as actually an
encouraging thing because regardless of
the Jordan Rhonda thing we can all agree
that LeBron James is a great basketball
player one of the greatest of all time
and probably the greatest who's playing
today and even if you know nothing about
basketball those are just facts right
now especially if you know yeah
but but what's encouraging is you know
what one of the greatest people can fail
this many times and part of that is what
makes them great is being able to to go
back and say alright now I need to
figure this out again and what we're
talking about for your average person
who's 18 or 25 or 35 or 45 isn't they
don't have the same cost associated with
failures as LeBron James he has a whole
lot riding on on that failure we can
fail a whole lot and it doesn't matter
to millions of people like it does to
they're failing like LeBron James does
yeah it's you know I look at that that
pressure we put on ourselves oh I forgot
to find the one thing I want to do the
rest of my life I don't know why we have
that ingrained in us I don't if you were
to tell me Josh or if you're gonna tell
ya if you were to tell me hey Ryan uh
we're gonna be podcasting for the rest
of your life and that's the only thing
we're gonna do we're gonna you know
we're gonna get out this the special
that we're working on but but we're just
going to podcast like that would be a
little scary for me yeah you know with
the minimalist yes like we're the
minimalists we you know we talk about
simplicity we we go on book tours we
give talks but there's a wide variety of
things that we are doing within the
minimalist it's not just this one task
yeah so I you know I guess this is my
way of just telling our audience that
you don't have to pick something that
you're gonna do for the rest of your
life in fact I would say for the average
person it's probably they're probably
not gonna do only one thing
yeah their life yeah and so maybe it
gets down to attenuating that timespan
pretty radical
what are you gonna do for the rest of
the day what are you gonna do for the
rest of the week what are you gonna do
for the rest of the year and committing
to that time frame we're gonna talk a
little bit obsessed adei as well and how
obsession you know can obviously be a
bad thing and often we associate it as a
bad thing but I often think you and I
were having a brief conversation of the
day and you were asking me about like my
bandwidth and how do I do some of the
things I do and I said well I just get
obsessed about certain things yeah and I
use that obsession to my own benefit
before we dive into the questions today
a couple follow-up items from last week
Ryan well we we did that podcast about
mementos and trinkets and the freshmaker
yeah no no that's we'll have a sponsor
oh okay nor will we have one because
advertisements suck although if we did
do advertisers right here is where they
would go but I've been doing these these
living room conversations you've been
joining me for some of them we're just
recording quick videos in my living room
answering one question a day throughout
this entire month and someone asked me
when is it okay to throw away my
partner's things so I answered that over
on YouTube plus there's thirty other
videos there you can find it youtube.com
slash the minimalists I thought it was a
perfect sort of a company video to last
week's momentos podcast and then also we
forgot to mention this we announced a
simply southern tour we're doing three
cities in the South you're not the only
person who's going to the South next
month we are headed down to Birmingham
Nashville and Louisville we're gonna be
with Chris Hogan and Anthony O'Neal and
Rachel Cruz we're doing a three city
tour we're talking about money and
minimalism but there's one thing I
forgot to mention Ryan Canyon City is
going to open up all three events for us
yeah we got a music a special guest open
yeah yeah so he's gonna come out keep
Paul from Canyon City he's gonna come
out and open up with some some music you
can find all the information to that
over at our website the minimalists com
slashed or all three dates there you can
grab your tickets before they sell out
and one other thing I forgot to mention
so I wrote it down here
there are two types of tickets you can
get like regular seated tickets and then
there are the VIP tickets which gets you
sort of the best seats in the house but
also we do a pre-show meet-and-greet
where we do you know photos and hugs and
all that fun stuff but we also most
importantly have a conversation sort of
a more intimate setting only like 50
people show up for the little VIP event
beforehand so you're welcome to join us
for that as well the minimalists comm
for all the details are let's dive into
these questions you know our first
question is from Elijah in San Diego I
was able to go and buy a house complete
a successful career in the Marine Corps
it gained a degree I thought I wanted
and build out the family that I was
looking for the problem is those were my
goals since I was a little kid and now
I'm left wondering what do I do with
that think you guys recently did stuff
so I'm trying to figure out how do I
find out what is most important to me in
life and how to shape my career and
personal goals around what is most
important to me in life all right so TK
it sounds like Elijah has some really
good problems here great problems in
fact in his 20s he got the house he
wanted the career he wanted the family
he wanted the degree he wanted and I
think that's part of the problem right
we often think like well now it's a
checklist yeah I identify with that more
than anyone because I'm so OCD I'm like
legitimately OCD and like for me I feel
so good
I'll put seven things on my task list
just so I could check them off I'm like
I picked up bleach at Target today I
feel accomplished and and quite often we
mistake accomplishment for meaningful
accomplishment or meaningful work or we
mistake productivity you know getting
things done go go go with something that
is actually worthwhile and so maybe you
could talk a little bit about that he's
saying what now how do I find out what
is most important to me so I can pursue
it well first I want to say
congratulations man on being in a
position where you have achieved so many
goals so early on in life if I heard
that correctly he said he's put himself
in a position of
my house at 20 it's got the family that
he wanted a man you know kudos to you I
mean you're basically trying to figure
out you know you're LeBron right now
you're trying to figure out how you're
gonna win your fourth championship you
know now that I have everything I've
ever wanted now what do I do right now
that I'm living the dream how do I get
that that second MVP award or whatever
it is good to contextualize it in that
way to know that you're in a good place
because the foundation that you're going
to be working from is the sense of pride
and accomplishment that comes from
achieving the things that that you've
set out to achieve what I would say
about this is I would prioritize
discovery over dogma discovery is when
you look for what's interesting to you
Dogma is when you look for the right
thing to do or the right thing to
believe and so many times when we set
out to figure out well what's next we
start with you know what's the right
answer and when we run to mentors and
experts and look for them to you know
tell us well based on your personality
type or your income or the city that you
live in this is what you ought to do and
and and not only do those guarantees not
exist in the real world but that's not
always the best way to even arrive at an
answer you know sometimes we we take
this scientific approach where we treat
the truth about what we does what we
need as if it's some object of fact out
there in the real world that we have to
go discover but I think there's another
approach and it's the artistic approach
and that's the art of making things up
you know and I think we have to give
ourselves freedom to make up some of the
answer some of the best answers in life
are not a matter of right and wrong
they're a matter of hey this feels good
this looks interesting that sounds cool
what's the right music to listen to is
it my music is it your music no man
you've got to make this answer up so
it's it's part discovery and part art
you know art and so what I would say is
you know here's a story I just recently
read Richard Saul Wurman he's the
founder of TED Talks I talked about at
HUD 45 he was a failed architect a
failed entrepreneur didn't know what to
do next and so he decided for the first
time in his life he would just give
himself permission to indulge in his
curiosities and so what he started to do
was he started with just identifying
places in LA which is where he lived
that he wanted to visit and he would go
check
different places and he would take notes
and he eventually started to publish
them as access guides and and they were
not his expertise they were not like
these are the top places in LA you
should visit it's just these are the
places that I'm curious about and I'm
checking them out and I'm taking notes
and I'm publishing my notes and those
things just went crazy and he began to
make a lot of money and the next step he
took is he said all right you know what
sounds interesting to me is just having
dinner parties all the time where I
invite cool intellectuals over and I get
to ask them questions and pick their
brains so he literally started having
idea meetups where he got together with
people and would pick their brain and
have them do little presentations and
that eventually went on to become TED
Talks
you know now what if he had said what's
the right thing for me to do right um
but instead he started with his
curiosity and he had enough faith in
that I believe it was Henry David
Thoreau who says that no one has ever
followed their curiosity to the point of
being misled start with what's
interesting to you and and luckily
you're in a position where you don't
sound like you have the financial
pressure to rush an answer or to do
something that you don't enjoy doing
because you need to pay a bill by this
Friday so take your time indulge what's
fascinating to you and see where that
leads yeah I totally agree man you know
the first thing I thought of with
allegis question was is he clear on his
values and beliefs we talk about this
all the time because for me and I think
for Josh too I mean that is that's our
foundation so when I think about like
what I truly value it's you know health
relationships cultivating passion
growing contributing I kind of look at
those five areas like all right which if
I'm feeling a little discontent I'll
look at those five areas and say okay
which of these five buckets is is the
most empty where where have I been
you know what have I been neglecting my
values and beliefs and that's usually
where I will start with with taking
action on something especially you know
if he could combine some curiosity with
this maybe for him it's contributing so
he could go out of his way to maybe take
his kids make it a family thing go out
contribute more learn about some other
nonprofits other things that he's been
interested in but yeah just just the
totally agree with you man like yeah I
think that he needs to find what he's
excited about
he needs to be clearing his values and
beliefs and just kind of explore a
little bit don't don't put pressure the
one thing I will say to Elijah don't put
pressure on yourself to make money from
what excites you because like you said
you put yourself in a situation where
you're like oh now I need to make money
from something I mean he can really
throw you off course they can kill the
excitement yeah it can kill the passion
that Elijah has been cultivating but
yeah because that's one thing he
specifically said was how do I shape my
career and I think you know what he does
next and how he shapes his career I
think that's two separate questions
yeah do you agree with that I well it
reminds me of this essay that the TK
wrote and I was doing another one of
those I was doing so TK : about my
surprise party what he does TK Coleman
calm is his website and so you can find
his writings there the Praxis stuff is
discover praxis calm okay okay okay but
this was I actually was doing a living
room conversation in here I did a field
trip to the office with one of the
living room conversations someone's
asked me is like what if I can't do what
I'm passionate about as my work or
whatever and and I we get this question
all the time and I think it presupposes
that like there's one thing that you're
supposed to do or there's only one thing
you can be passionate about in fact we
you go to your average University we've
spoken at University I've literally seen
the successor EES poster on the wall it
says follow your passion and it sounds
like cool advice like yeah that's good
right it's fairly benign advice but the
truth is that presupposes that like you
were meant to be a doctor or yoga
instructor or an astronaut or something
but TK I'll just read a little bit of
this we'll put the link to this in the
show notes as well your personal
happiness is not a career nor is your
career the end-all be-all to your
personal happiness yes I know that your
happiness is your job and that you're
the CEO of your own fulfillment yeah
I've read a copy of happiness as an
inside job too but I'm not playing
semantic games here I mean business no
one is going to pay you for your
positive emotions and nothing that you
ever get paid for
we'll be responsible for every emotion
you feel your happiness and your job
will always be separate things even if
you have the happiest job in the world
why because they're all there always be
exciting beautiful and inspiring
possibilities to explore that you are
not directly they're not directly
connected to your work that you receive
paychecks for I don't get paid to drink
water but I do it anyway because it
keeps me alive ditto for eating food
sleeping at night taking walks watching
stand-up comedy checking sports scores
reading graphic novels studying
philosophy taking hikes visiting
Botanical Gardens and a host of other
activities that are essential to keeping
my body mind and spirit and
relationships alive no one wants to give
me money for these things but I
absolutely have to do them and guess
what I also love my job and he goes into
talking quite a bit about that but we'll
put a link to that but it reminded me of
the exploration that you're talking
about and maybe not thinking about
getting tied up and like the next thing
I do has to be the next thing that I do
for money and the thing that I would add
to that is maybe the only other thing
that I have to say about this is if I'm
in his if I'm in Elijah's position right
now the only advice I would give to
myself is create more and consume less
yeah and by creating more whether that's
writing if you want to start a blog we
have a great resource on our website how
to start a blog if you want to start a
podcast it's the thing to do if you if
you want to start a stand-up comedy or
improv that's creation and that that's
the creative process and through doing
that you're inevitably going to fail
you're gonna write that first blog post
and very few people are going to read it
another K when you first moved here you
you sort of started blogging just
because and you were just start you
started creating right and that led to
several all the things and and we have
these little ripple effects in time that
that one little creation if you create
more and more and more people start to
find value in it and that going to find
value in everything but you're gonna
find value in the process and you're
going to learn what people find to be
valuable
and then of course you can do more of
that yeah and when you can add value to
someone's life and if the more people
you add value to the more people are
willing to support you I mean with the
minimalists we didn't sell anything for
the first year and you know eventually
Josh and I were like oh we're the
minimalists we should write a book on
minimalism and people were people were
very eager people were very eager people
were very eager to go out of their way
and support us to buy the book to show
up at our events and and yeah Alijah
find find what excites you find how you
can add value to other people's lives
and if you can do that you'll probably
find a way to make some money off of it
but I just want to say like for Elijah
and anyone else out there don't
pigeonhole yourself into choosing a job
that you feel like you're gonna wake up
and be passionate about every single day
of your life because because I think
when it comes to a career there are two
different types of approaches it is well
there are two of many I'm sure but
here's the two that I think of is you
know yes you can look at what you love
let's go with the teaching example I
love you know working with kids I would
love to be a teacher I'm going to go to
school to be a teacher and I'm gonna
chase what I am passionate about that's
one approach I think the other approach
to is okay what can I do to earn a
living to put food on the table to
provide for my family but yet still have
time outside of work
to do the things that excite me the most
- to explore the things that my family
and I really really want to want to go
out and do the job doesn't necessarily
have to be something that someone is
passionate about I do think that
someone's job has to align with their
values and beliefs because I mean you
know like if I found a job and it was
killing puppies like I don't know why
that always comes to my head because I'm
really against killing puppies that's
why Josh uh-huh but but why but you know
if that's what the job involves like
every day I would feel like I was going
against who I was I think that's where
we can run into a problem but me you
know being a barista I mean I do happen
to be passionate about coffee I love
coffee but showing up and making
espressos and making drinks for people
maybe that's not what I'm super excited
about but if
I could do that 30 40 hours a week and
still have time outside of that to to
work on my health to work on my
relationships to grow to contribute to
cultivate a passion that to me is also
another approach so yeah just just again
Alijah don't force yourself to make
money off of what you're passionate
about that's that's not the only way to
do it right I think that that often we
confuse excitement with passion too
right and we we get really excited about
an idea and then of course when that
excitement wanes as it inevitably does
then we try we just hop we hop around
the next thing we think we might be
passionate about because well I'm not
excited about this anymore I must not be
passionate about I think real passion
comes from putting in the work drudging
through the drudgery being willing to to
fail through that process and realizing
like oh just because this isn't fun in
the moment doesn't mean this isn't what
I'm passionate about fact real passion
comes from that really difficult work
the dip is a Seth Godin would call it
and and and working through that dip
until we get to the other side of it
okay can I throw out something yeah so
yeah I like that so the root of the word
passion actually means to suffer and so
the implication is - is how much are you
willing to suffer on behalf of X that's
what it means to say I'm passionate
about X that's where the whole idea of
The Passion of the Christ comes from the
passion is the willingness to suffer you
know for the sins of humanity so as an
analogy let's say you know for what it
means to follow something let's say I'm
let's say my dog is running away from me
and I'm chasing after my dog so I can be
said to be following my dog and pursuing
my dog and he's running around corners
and I'm going around the corners
everywhere he goes I'm going and then
there's one point where my dog jumps
over a fence and I get to the fence and
I say well I don't want to ruin my
t-shirt I'm not jumping over that fence
am i following my dog am i pursuing my
dog
no I'm I was following my dog but I'm
following my obstacle now I'm pursuing
my obstacle right because because I
stopped chasing after the thing right
and so a lot of great example then yeah
a lot of times people people are you
know like in order to follow your
fashion
in order to follow your passion alright
say about that anything about everything
follow your fashion hey what's that all
about
but in order for me to follow my dog in
this instance what do I have to do I
have to go beyond that obstacle right I
have to hop over the gate and go beyond
it if I'm not willing to do that then
I'm not a passionate person I'm not
pursuing that so a lot of times we say
well I want to follow my passion and we
equate that to mean we equate that with
meaning I want to do what feel cos feels
good all the time
but following your passion means
pursuing what you believe in even past
the point of your obstacle another thing
you talked about making sure things line
up with your values one of the negative
consequences of placing so much emphasis
on following your passion is that there
are a lot of people who now buy into
this notion that there are some kind of
sellout for not doing something that
they love so you have people that are
plumbers and electricians they're making
a good living they're providing for
their family
they've been feeling pretty proud they
don't particularly love what they do but
they're you know they're they're content
they're doing well they're working hard
and now they're thinking to themselves
well is this a bad thing should I be
feeling more excited at my job and while
I think it's totally legit to say I want
to figure out a way to translate what
excites me into an income there's
something dangerous about getting into a
space where you're now feeling guilty
because you don't think you're an
example to the world of what it means to
follow your passion so just make sure
that as you're trying to follow your
passion you're following your passion
not the passion you think you ought to
have in order to live a life that's
impressive to other people yeah man no I
totally agree like to any plumber or
electrician anyone out there that's got
you know this job that maybe isn't like
sexy and exciting and it's not you know
changing the world but if someone is in
that role and like they are that you
know for all intents and purposes
they're happy or they feel like they're
living a meaningful life like that's
everyone everyone who's asking these
questions that's all they want yeah they
just want to find something where they
can come home put their head in their
pillow go to sleep and say you know what
like yeah I'm not I'm not changing the
world
my dent in the universe but I feel
really good and let and and that's
that's okay but you're right man like
judging or not judging but feeling
judged and starting to look at how other
people pursue their career I don't know
why I'm having so much trouble talking
today so anybody can really it can
really hurt or yeah our pursuit I think
that that I have news for those people
as well um I make a living as a writer
and it is not exciting 95% of the time
in fact it's only exciting because yeah
the old quote you know writers don't
like writing they like having written
and and it's so true like I there I get
to a point where I all of a sudden I do
feel really good or I feel accomplished
but I imagine it's the same way that
like when I used to wash dishes way I
would feel really accomplished by like
somehow I we got through the crazy
dinner rush and all of a sudden like I
don't know how we cleared all those
dishes and 45 minutes but we did in I
felt accomplished afterward it's the
same thing with writing I think it's the
same thing with any profession most of
what you do most of the time is not
going to be exciting and that's okay in
fact if it's always exciting it's
probably an indicator that it's too
comfortable and and those obstacles
create the discomfort you need to grow
yeah I love that
so um instead of following your passion
also experiment with the concept of
flirting with your passion so as an
example with your passion or with your
passion so as an example let's say some
young guy comes in here and he says hey
guys I'm you know I'm successful I got a
good job but I want to be married I want
to have a wife and I want to start a
family what are some tips on finding a
good wife and then we started talking to
him saying stuff like hey man you know
don't worry about that too much just get
out there and meet people live your life
do things you're interested in try to
make friends that kind of feels like a
consolation prize when people that are
married are telling you that right at
least it felt like that for me once it
once upon my 24 the time yeah I felt
like a consolation prize like oh that's
easy for you to say you already have
your wife right yeah but there's
something to be said about
approach because that approach actually
protects you from something very
dangerous and that is it protects you
from going on a first date and being so
obsessed with the end result that you
say as you're getting to know that
person so where is this going
you know um you're never gonna get
anywhere with anyone if you talk about
marriage on the first date right you're
gonna freak them out and everything's
gonna go wrong can't even talk about it
on the second date or the third day now
I know somebody's gonna be all of the
YouTube comments like well I actually
love it is always a large man yeah yeah
but but generally speaking it's it
sounds like a cop-out it sounds like
disappointing advice but it works like
magic it's actually how things work in
life that you start at the level of not
putting pressure on your relationships
by saying where this is going and you
say hey let's just have coffee you know
let's just have a conversation let's see
where this leads and if this is fun
maybe we'll do this a second time with
no pressure for anything else and that's
how you got to do with your curiosities
and your passions as well if you try too
early to force it into something that
can generate an income you won't learn
very interesting things about it that
could be a pivotal part of that process
later on yeah I'm gonna say two things
about that but I'm gonna save it for our
next question because so standards and
goals versus direction we need to get to
both of those because you and I have
touched on those in the past and
writings and I think now would be a good
time to bring that onto the podcast and
and maybe have a discussion or even a
debate with with dk about about goals
versus direction but before we do that
Elijah I'd love to send you a copy of
our book everything that remains it's
still my favorite thing that we've ever
written it's a memoir about five years
of Ryan and I going from being a
suit-and-tie corporate guys to becoming
minimalist but of course it didn't just
happen overnight we didn't just follow
our passion we didn't just put our jobs
and start a blog no but we we and we
didn't just walk away from one lifestyle
we found something to walk toward and I
think that's what Elijah is looking for
right now instead of just walking away
from one thing in fact Elijah has built
the the foundation yesterday's
accomplishments are tomorrow's
foundation he already has a really solid
foundation and wherever you are you have
some sort of foundation right now
and you may want to added that
foundation before you build on it but in
that book everything that remains Elijah
we talked about sort of taking the
foundation and everything that we
learned the skills and talents that we
had developed over a dozen or so years
after growing up poor then making it
into the the corporate world and being
all sensibly successful and moving that
forward to be something completely
different and and so I'd love to send
you a copy of the audio book if you like
our podcast you like the audio book
version of that or if you want the book
book or the e-book we'll send those to
you as well I think you you mentioned
something I don't know if you were you
know intentionally trying to be profound
or not
well walking towards something like we
we walked towards the minimalists it was
not something that we ran towards oh yes
and and often and I think Elijah's in
the spot where he's like what do I run
to what do I run towards I gotta find
something to run towards and it's like
dude just take a walk it don't and
people we often want to run away from
something to like I want to tell one to
this corporate general like once I
realize I can no longer aligns with a
person I aspire to be I wanted to run
away from like a burning building but
here's the thing it wasn't a burning
building it was a job that paid my bills
that was helping me get out of debt
mm-hmm we weren't killing puppies that I
am aware of I know I wasn't but but the
truth is like I wanted to walk away from
that and walk towards something else in
order to do that you don't have to just
sprint in the other direction you know
that can lead to a world of hurt as well
it's a great point our next question is
from Shania in Maine I just had a
question about how to accept the fact
that I don't really know what I'm doing
with my life I I didn't go to college
and I don't feel the need to go to
college but I often find it really hard
to not feel embarrassed about not going
to college because I feel like everyone
in college is working toward something
and while I have a job and things like
that I feel like I'm working but not
toward something and I just I don't know
how to
there and I don't know how to not feel
embarrassment people absolute all like
working if you and you go to school and
I'm like no I don't and I just feel a
little judge every time I say that but
my mom had sir please that are all nice
and I mean that is just not something I
like I think about you see and I just
really struggle with accepting the fact
that I don't know what I'm doing I don't
know what I want to do and I feel really
pressured to figure it out and get all
my shapes together like overnight and I
I guess I just want to know how can I
make this depth to one accepting that
not going to college is just not for
media not feeling judge but also how do
i how do I figure this [ __ ] out you know
I'm only 21 and I don't know what I want
to do and really getting down to me well
I have bad news if you haven't figured
it out by age 21
[Music]
you know I do not listen to Josh well
actually it made me think of this essay
I wrote a really long time ago it's
probably seven years ago six seven years
ago it's called when goals are important
and when they are not and I'm gonna read
a quick seven from those we'll put a
link to it in the show notes as well
people have all sorts of clever words to
describe what they do what they want to
do objective target plan in game outcome
goal if you know me then you know I was
the gold guy when I was in the corporate
world I had financial goals health goals
sales goals vacation goals even consumer
purchase goals I [ __ ] you none
I had spreadsheets of goals precisely
tracking and measuring and readjusting
my plans accordingly these days life is
different and I no longer want any goals
in my life instead instead of an
arbitrary target I prefer to have a
direction in which I travel if you're
searching for a sunrise it's important
to be headed east for a sunset West I do
however believe there was a time in my
life and goals were die early and
when I was in a hole and needed to get
out truth be told most of my goals
ridiculous or irrelevant
purchasing and accumulation goals for
example but a few of my goals helped
immensely like getting out of dead or
losing all that weight I lost like 80
pounds I like it a lot of goals to
escaping a crater in the middle of a
desert when I was fat enough to my
eyeballs in debt lingering in that
bowl-shaped cavity my goal was to break
free from the sun-scorched Basin and
fine Earth's surface and so I tended to
I'll skip the rest of the essay here but
I tend to delineate between goals Ryan
you and I often talk about wanting to
extend
TK's point about Elijah's question we
talked about raising our standards below
our expectations and I think one way to
maybe reframe that for some folks is
instead of having a goal have a
direction in which you want to travel
right you're living in Dayton Ohio and
yeah instead of I want to end up in LA
maybe it's I want to go west you know
who knows maybe you'll end up in San
Diego or or Seattle and that'll be a
better experience for you and you're not
so tethered to whatever that outcome
might be I think sometimes however the
outcomes are important but in Shania's
case it doesn't tell if she has a
massive amount of debt she doesn't have
all this weight to lose there isn't this
crater from which she needs to escape
the crater she needs to escape from
right now is a self-imposed crater she's
feeling the pressure but I think most of
that pressure maybe 99% of it is
internal pressure and by the way the
external pressure that she's feeling if
someone is truly judging you like oh I
can't believe Shania is not going to
college and racking up all that debt
can't believe she's 21 years old and
doesn't have a figured out yeah I mean
that those people are not just
unreasonable but but they their
expectations are their own they don't
doesn't mean they have to be your
expectations you know it may when you're
talking about you know the standards
versus expectations or maybe you know
changing direction I think about how you
know you and I've been talking about
this book I've been working on and yes
my outcome is like man I really would
like to finish this book however that
that outcome is not really it's not
really driving me to get the book
finished so what you and I talked about
a couple weeks ago is all right man
just look at it as setting three hours
aside one hour three different days
schedule it in your calendar and start
working on the book just start there
with three hours in that just in the
last two weeks has it's just helped me
focus and in what you told me to is like
as soon as that hour runs up stop stop
medicine yeah I don't keep going but but
I I guess what I'm trying to share here
is that yes like there is an outcome
that I want there is I guess you could
say it's a goal but I have kind of
removed that goal and have changed my
approach so now it's about raising my
standards in the sense that I'm working
on this thing consistently I can look in
the mirror and say yes Ryan you've put
at least three hours into it this week
and that will eventually help me to get
to that outcome that I want but but it's
kind of removed that pressure for myself
to have it all figured out right now
when we talk about raising your stands
lowering your expectations I think
you've maybe intentionally or maybe even
unintentionally that's this is what
happens with standards that they tend to
raise on their own would you get good at
something you raise your standard
because when we first had the
conversation it was two hours it was one
hour twice a week basically and stopped
at that one hour but if you can do three
that means you've raised your standard I
mean you're talking about 50% increased
productivity I'll say one other thing
I'll let TK jump in here but Lao Zhu he
said a good traveler has no fixed plans
and is not intent on arriving I think
the book writing process is off in that
way with me
i-i've started since writing everything
that remains I've started four different
books and none of them have turned into
books but I haven't been intent
arriving and they I knew when to stop
we're not even stop but win the set it
aside and start over or start something
new and it's because my standards are
really high and the process of writing
for me is in many ways the reward going
through through that writing process for
me is that is the the outcome you know
in many ways it's just sitting down in
the chair and doing the work and if it
if it manifests into something later
then that's great
tell me I'm wrong TK here I'm curious
you guys ever felt like that like I have
no idea where I'm going oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean I well it depends I
mean I think I feel like that on little
things all the time even now it's like I
feel that now like not every single day
but there are moments where I'm like
what that what the hell are we doing
where we go right and and I think part
of that has to do with not being
comfortable with where we are right now
and and and it goes back to that crater
thing for me right like sometimes we we
are in these real craters I had it's
close to half a million dollars worth of
debt in my late 20s and and that I knew
I needed to go out of that and having a
goal to get out of that was was
important to me but it wasn't nearly as
important as actually doing the work to
get out of it like the goal can be fun
we can all have the goal to be debt-free
but so what if you don't do the work to
actually get there yeah yeah absolutely
man you know it's funny one of the best
things about growing older with each age
you realize it to a greater degree is
that no one has a clue we're all just
hiking it we're all just making it up as
we go along and when you when you go
back to that distinction I made earlier
between the scientific approach and the
artistic approach between treating all
answers as if they're objective truths
to be discovered versus some answers
needing to be made up it doesn't sound
so scandalous right like how did we get
a John Coltrane song like how do we get
how do we get music by Miles Davis how
do we get this kind of stuff how do we
get beethoven not by discovering things
that already exist but by giving
ourselves permission to just say hey no
one's ever done this before so there's
no right
answer for me to find let me just make
something up and put it out to the world
and then later on we treat that like
that's the right thing like that's the
classic that everybody studies but well
you know and also like you in retrospect
it's easy to point out the successes
right we and I think that's the the
dangerous thing with nostalgia these
days is like we look back and say oh you
know the the 50s were so great yeah if
you were a white male in the 50s right
and even then it wasn't awesome either
because what if you were working in a
coal mine like yeah there are these
things where you let you you you look
back to to the past and you tweeze out
only the good things that you remember
mm-hmm and you leave behind all the the
the actual the reality of the situation
because reality is this commingling of
good and bad and pleasure and suffering
and everything in between and the stal
just plucks out the things that are
conveniently pleasurable yeah but one of
the things this is like a total aside
but one of the things when people are
like oh yeah the good old days the good
old days people used to be so you know
community oriented and like you know you
knew your neighbor and like I just want
to ask whoever saying that like what
one's the last time you've went out and
done something for your community like
when's the last time you went to meet
your neighbor and it mean just to your
point if people remember it how they
want to remember it yeah yeah and they
want to throw blame on how things used
to be versus how they are now and I
guess this is my way of saying like we
are in control of how we use our time
our attention and now can be the good
old days to now will eventually be the
good ones right yeah we're the bad old
days if we if we choose the wrong path
so so should I have actually her
question reminds me a little bit of you
have a person in your life a friend or
family member who reached out to you
recently and they're like hey can you
help me broadcast my voice a little bit
on social media right I'm trying to I'm
trying to figure out how to use social
media better and you guys have figured
this thing out clearly you have it all
figured out right which we don't at all
we could talk about that but
and really what they were looking for
was one of two things and I think quite
often we as humans get caught up in this
we're looking for either
I need the six step guide from A to Z to
make this thing work perfectly I want to
follow these seven easy steps in your
blog post and by this afternoon I should
have it all figured out and a hundred
thousand people should be following me
on Twitter you know it's funny oh so
let's talk about that that that way for
a second um why do why do we want that
as humans it's I think it's because well
one reason like a we want a clear-cut
formula we want something we want to put
our you know our head first and is
something that we know has proven to
work but the other thing too is that we
want an excuse to say oh that failed it
wasn't me these steps that was that that
were laid out in front of me they
weren't the right steps and it's because
of this plan that I have failed
I want to blame this other person or
this recipe as opposed to myself I think
what I'm getting at is like that
approach is like almost it's absolving
our responsibilities of failure yeah
essentially like it's this like pre this
pre work that we've done to you know
basically be able to point the finger if
it fails right and this is the other
path that they're looking for it's not
the six step guide or the 14 ways to do
Blanc they're looking for the hey Ryan
can you do this for me right you're good
at this saying that there's an old a
Pithom that if if you want to get
something done ask a busy person to do
it and because they clearly or the
productive person knows how to be of
wedge in another another project or
whatever and of course the problem is I
don't think shinai is asking this
necessarily but if you were to say you
know guy TK what are the six steps I can
do in order to you know not be
embarrassed or to figure it out
overnight or or to figure out what I
want to do with the rest of my life like
you could give her some steps but they
may not be necessarily the appropriate
steps for her right especially when we
get down to the more specifics or if she
said hey Ryan can you figure this out
for me that there's no reward in any of
that a lot of the reward is in the
exploration itself even if I if I waved
if we waved a magic wand right now
and gave Shania a purpose and let's say
like you know again that magic want put
her in this this perfect job this role
that you know she had a great question
for what do you do mm-hmm
she might just be calling and having
Elijah's question well now that I have
everything that I want now what do I do
exactly yeah so I I do write down some
the six steps for her to take but no
this is good like edit out everything I
just said what I do love no no what I do
love about that approach though the six
steps is that is it is at least a
framework at any time I look at steps
this isn't an end-all be-all as much as
it is direction exactly exactly you know
so for me I have something that I call
the mother of all advice and and the
mother of all advice is that there is no
piece of insight no matter who it comes
from or how awesome it is that isn't
fully capable of destroying your life if
you don't combine it with critical
thinking and creativity I don't care
what anyone tells you it can ruin your
life if you don't think for yourself and
if you don't exercise a little
imagination when you're working out the
details of how to sort out that truth in
your own life so never hide behind
advice never outsource personal
responsibility never put on anyone else
the need to work it out alright so there
are a few things I wanted to say so one
of the things that inspired us to to
start praxis was not just this desire to
reduce the transaction cost involved in
education you know to take it from six
figures to 11 thousand the goal was to
also reduce the social costs because for
people that opted out of college it's
pretty much Steve Jobs or bust you know
if you go to college and graduate you
can at least in theory be mediocre yeah
case in point just go out into the world
and find your own example okay everybody
with a college degree ain't happy
alright we can just keep that real at
least that one thing but when you drop
out of college you say this isn't for me
you better be a billionaire you know
what I mean like you better change the
world or we're just gonna look at you
and say well you should have done
college you sure you didn't live up to
your potential
you didn't go to college yeah if you
graduate with a degree in anthropology
and and maybe you're you're working at
Starbucks and you don't want to be there
like hey man that's life you know it's a
process you know like let's just keep
plugging away at it man I remember this
so you do a podcast called office hours
with Isaac Morehouse you're working on
season two right now yeah yeah we just
did the premiere episode last weekend oh
nice so I remember and I can I sent this
episode two to a few people you talked
about how also the the parents the the
cost is also on the parents like that
they we office say while our parents
want what's best for us yeah yeah and
your thought was like do they really
well well III think in theory we all
want what's best for ourselves right I
don't think anyone is consciously and
proactively working against their own
self-interest even if they seem as if
they are right my 25 year old so you
know but as the saying goes sincerity is
not a substitute for truth and the fact
that we want what's best for ourselves
and for others doesn't mean we're always
working with the best information and it
doesn't mean that we are without
conflict that we are without tension in
our decision-making process
and parents have all sorts of things
going on too and there's a social cost
for them as well now we've got a lot of
supportive parents of practice
participants who you know they really
get behind it for them and they really
champion them but even then there's kind
of a social cost sometimes they have to
take that defensive posture and say hey
look I stand by my son I stand by my
daughter he doesn't want to go to
college this is right for him and
sometimes their friends will look at
them a little weird and so all of that
stuff gets baked in and so sometimes
when people give you a hard time it's
not it's not because they're trying to
be cruel it's not because they're trying
to be dogmatic it's also because you're
venturing out into territory that's not
familiar to them and that's a little
frightened they're a little worried and
when you're young let's face it this
isn't a cruel thing but when you're 20
years old you haven't lived most of your
life and you're pretty much unproven you
haven't proven your ability to provide
yourself provide for yourself for the
long term it's very haven't proven your
ability to survive the harshness of the
world
there's a lot of crap out there to be
dealt with and it's not until you're you
know sometimes like in your 30s that
people start to say okay you know this
person's probably been through some
stuff
this person's probably been around for a
little bit right you know so it's
natural for people to worry about about
you when you're younger because they
just don't know how it's gonna take um
turn out so that leads me to my first
point my first point is don't argue
don't argue with people you don't have
to be a get something in order to be for
something you don't have to fight
against what you don't want to do in
order to take a stand for what you do
want to do and sometimes we confuse
following our passion with hating our
critics Wayne Dyer refer to something
called a sacred power of silence and he
says whenever you have a dream or a goal
don't argue with people trying to
justify your pursuit of that or else
your energy will go out in the direction
of other people's objections and you
need that energy for the creative
process so instead of arguing let people
have their opinions preserve your energy
for the creative process because
ultimately the best evidence of what you
want is are the results that you create
I wrote a blog post about this on the
Praxis blog discover practices calm the
name of the blog post is a note to young
dreamers who don't feel supported by
family and friends
I'll make sure Sean puts it in the notes
yeah and I talked about how you don't
have to be disrespectful in order to
disagree and and how to live an
unconventional life even when people
that you love are worried about you so
that's my first thing just opt out of
the arguments you know when you can
terminate the conversation exit the
conversation entirely when you have to
be there listen
be respectful let people know you
respectfully disagree but don't argue
you know think about think about
tug-of-war if a person is pulling on one
end of the rope and you're pulling on
the other other end of the rope well you
got a nice good game of tug-of-war but
if you let go of that rope there's
nothing that people can do yeah you know
will they fall on their ass
well yeah they fall on their ass I saw
Michael malleus do this on Twitter the
other day where someone said to him
Michael you're a jerk and he goes and
and they said and you're stupid and he
goes okay and they were just like man
there's no way he just dropped that rope
alright so that's the first thing second
speed through these
best piece of advice I've ever received
came from Peter Daniels who said over
the course of your lifetime read a
thousand biographies because in doing so
you'll build a vast vocabulary for
overcoming incredible odds it is
absolutely important that you that you
contextualize your life in terms of what
has taken place already in history
absolutely I think that the most
self-defeating thought is I'm the only
one that's gone through this or I'm some
rare individual who is facing for the
first time in human history
this particular plight this particular
question there are lots of people who've
dropped out of school who've opted out
of college who are not you know making
six figures but they're really happy
with their lives they found a way to
carve their own path and you have to
follow the advice of Timothy Leary which
is find the others you've got to find
those people you cannot do this alone so
I mean it's one of the reasons why we
built practices to give people that kind
of community and one of the ways you can
find that out like you can there's a
podcast called the successful dropout
podcast go listen to that podcast like
by the end of this year make it a goal
to have listened to the story of at
least 25 people that have opted out of
college it's not going to give you the
answers but it will give you a sense of
community and a sense of perspective it
also give you some templates but or
maybe some recipes and you don't have to
follow the exact recipe but you got an
ingredient here here here and here
and all of a sudden you're starting to
make your own recipe yeah absolutely
they're all pieces of the puzzle oh you
know also check out our for tilt podcast
and our blog at praxis we give a lot of
advice to people who you know are
looking to create their life opting out
of college thirdly and I only got four
thoroughly refused to be defined by your
degree when people ask you what you're
up to
don't tell them a story about what
you're not doing tell them a story about
what you are doing even if you don't
know what where that's going to lead in
the future I call this I call this
changing and turning a noun into a verb
so the most dangerous question what do
you do like we and it's the first
question we always ask people right but
if pigeonholes us into your degree or
your job title as opposed in that that's
not what you do that is a noun that
there's no verb
they're what I'm the Director of
Operations that doesn't tell me anything
about what you do as a human being or
even what you do in your work really
what that hold is director of operations
for the assistant vice president
president mean like it doesn't mean
anything it's just this sort of jargon
right and so why not instead talk about
what you do and sense of like I'm
passionate about this or I'm excited
about this or I'm working on this or I
do I do these things
yeah exactly you don't have to you know
give some full one-page explanation for
why you're not doing something like
college or anything else just talk about
what you're doing I remember at one
point in my life I I dated someone for
several years and we were a popular
couple a lot of people knew us and and
we broke up and you know for the first
few months every time I go somewhere by
myself friends would be like hey so you
know you know where's that girl or how
are things going and I felt like if
people presented a question I was
obligated to answer it in full and so I
would relive the story a million times
over and I'd be like well this happened
in that Appling and that happened in
blah blah blah and by the time I'm done
rehashing that story for the sake of
their curiosity right I'm feeling pretty
down and I'm feeling pretty defensive I
got you in the same state over me in the
same state over and over again and so
what's happened to Shania right now just
we're asking her she's like she gets
down and she doesn't have the the sort
of defense mechanism to try to deal with
us she just gets back into this state of
I feel icky now yeah yeah and one of our
fundamental rights as a pre political
given is that we don't have to answer
every question that is presented to us
we have the right to redirect a
conversation along more desired lines
and so what I did in that situation as I
said okay wait a minute man my need to
move on with my life is more important
than the satiation of other people's
curiosities so even though I love my
friends I love the people from my past
from now on I'm gonna place a higher
priority on where I'm going what I'm
working on and not where I've been and
why that didn't work out and so I
started running into people and they'd
be like hey so what happened in that
situation I'll tell you I was just
saying man let me tell you what's
happening right now and you'll be amazed
at how much people respect that they'll
say oh okay yeah tell me what's
happening right now you know and it
works so don't let people
force you into a conversation you don't
want to have about why you're not doing
something
tell them how excited you are about the
book you're reading tell them how
excited you are or what you're learning
from the job you're at or how proud you
are about that last thing number four
give your bucket list a break here's
what I mean by that I I think one of the
plight of being you know as young as 20
is that you have a lot of older people
that are telling you with all sincerity
things like now is the time because one
day you're gonna be married and you're
gonna have kids and you're gonna have a
bunch of external obligations and
without meaning to say it we basically
let them know that experimentation
travel fun trying things out that's over
yeah that's a wrap right ten layers from
being [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah welcome
to prison right and we don't intend to
convey that message we're just trying to
let them know that they do kind of have
a unique opportunity to be flexible and
take a higher risk than what you can
take when you have a family which is
true which is totally true and they need
to know it but but there's another
element that gets hurt and we don't
intend to convey this element but the
element that gets heard is okay I got 10
years to to make sure I do
everything that's important to answer
all the great philosophical questions
about Who I am and what the meaning of
my life is to go to every country to
find out my passion because when I'm 30
my opportunity to do that is over and I
and so it compresses our life to this
like five year timespan you know and so
now we got to get it all done and I
think that's a big part of the anxiety
that 19 and 20 year olds and young
people have about figuring out what they
want to do it's that they've been
convinced that they only have so much
time to figure it out and get on with it
because they gotta be locked in to
permanency at 30 and you don't I speak
to you from the other side and I tell
you yes there are more responsibilities
yes there are more challenges but life
is good over here too and and and and
there's an opportunity within marriage
within family life within owning a
business to explore to learn new things
and to evolve and give yourself that
room to breathe
I got I have written down here it goes
hand-in-hand with what you were saying
with number two about reading the
biographies I mean what I have written
down is find people you want to emulate
and maybe right now she doesn't have
anyone that she wants to emulate I think
reading biographies is a great way to do
that but ultimately like if I was in her
shoes I would I would find people I
wanted to emulate and then I would find
other people that I can associate with
who are either similar to the people I
want to emulate or they're into the same
things that I want to emulate but but
getting out there and finding a
supportive group of people to help
explore your curiosity to help kind of
further further your I want to say
career but like she shouldn't be focused
on career right now it's all about
exploring and finding things that's
interesting to her well in in the the
finding the people you want to emulate
but then also adding value to their
lives is the thing that sold out on top
of that yeah I think immediately of
Justin Moloch who has a great podcast
called optimal living daily you we went
to the comedy store he was there and
he's become a friend of ours now and he
just reached out said hey can I read
some of your essays I'm saying that's
thinking of starting a podcast now he
has this wildly successful podcast it
all started because he everyone want he
would read one essay a day and started
with the minimalists essays and that
turned into a relationship where we
hired him to do the audiobook versions
of our books because he's so good he's
reading our work and he reads a bunch of
other people's work like their except
ours or or brené Brown he just he is
great at finding these these essays to
read and giving someone that's the sort
of daily bit of knowledge that they can
you know it's his little snippet of let
me walk away with something but he came
to us and said hey I really like what
these guys are doing let me find a way
to add value to their lives first and
then all of a sudden it's like yeah this
guy has good motives he's not like
trying to get one over on us or anything
he just wanted that value to our lives
he did something that we couldn't do for
ourselves and it helped us now we've
been friends ever since yeah I'd love
out a new element of that story when I
met
his wife Olivia at the at the comedy
show so the way that he even started
reading these essays and thinking about
doing a podcast was he would read to
Olivia at night I didn't know that and
she's like man Justin you really need to
start like recording this stuff like
you've a really good voice so you know
just from like I just love that trend
that trend transition of like he him and
his wife had this this moment at night
that he would read to her before they
went to bed yeah and that was something
that they enjoyed doing right Olivia
just kind of mentioned like you really
should record this stuff it's really
really good so then he started to flirt
with that a little bit and it's just
this great it's just a great story of
how you can take one small thing and
just cultivate it and eventually and
then eventually you know it turns into
something and he didn't plan on I'm
gonna start this podcast in Peyer he has
several different podcast now he has
optimal business daily and he is several
other people he works with now and
they're recording several daily podcast
and he's enjoying that process but it
just came from exploring that a little
bit of curiosity and I kind of like this
and eventually and this is the last
thing I'll leave Shanaya was I never got
to move on here but find something to
get obsessed about over time and but
you're not gonna be obsessed about it
immediately it may be the thing to do
and this is something I learned from
Derek Siver's something I wish I would
have done at scheana's age because you
were mentioning about I would tell
people about what book you're reading
right now what you're doing right now
start a now page Derek Siver's I think
it's now now now calm that takes you to
his now page there or if you just go to
Silver's org slash now it's like hey
here's what I'm reading right now here's
what I'm working on right now and one of
two things will happen you'll be able to
articulate exactly what's going on right
now people say what do you do you can
just go right into what your now page
says for this week or this month or
whatever or you're gonna realize like oh
I'm not I'm not really doing anything
with my life I need to do something
that's worth writing about yeah that's
where that's where I shifted from
writing fiction in my 20s to writing
nonfiction in my 30s was because I
finally started living a life that was
worth
writing about before I had to write
about these fictional lives because my
life was certainly not worth writing
about at all dude I've got this line
written down and I really it's I think
it's uh it's kind of two overarching but
you let me know what you think about
this if if Shania can pursue meaning the
more we pursue meaning the more things
will fall into place and I'm not trying
to just say like alright quit your job
and pursue meaning right but the more
that we can focus on meaning in a
responsible way I think it and you can
also find meaning in what you're doing
right now if she's if he's working as a
barista you can find a lot of meaning in
that experience right I have great
conversations with the coffee shop right
across the street every single day
yesterday I've been going to that coffee
shop for I mean ever since we've been in
this studio and finally Daniel over
there was like I've realized who you are
and like I see you every single day and
I saw your documentary like two years
ago and like all of a sudden changed
everything but we had already built up
this really great rapport and it had
nothing to do with what I do creatively
or for a living we just had meaningful
interactions that were relatively brief
and so it's finding meaning even in the
fleeting moments yeah and if you could
do that enough then all of a sudden
you're gonna feel a lot more meaning and
overall life so yeah it is it is a broad
thing to say to say find meaning but
what else is there to find yeah are you
gonna say find passivity oh yeah that's
not going to be rewarding for any of us
right now there's a reason that we don't
have Twitter and Instagram on our phones
right because I'll just pacify myself
with it all day tagged on to that is you
know one question we can ask ourselves
is what use is the ideal set of
circumstances if you are not the person
who's optimized for that right like for
every great scenario we can put the
wrong person in it so for instance I
always dream of like taking the
game-winning NBA shot right but if you
put me in that situation now do you
dream of like phalam Byron Russell back
no foul those referees are paid
professionals they're making the call
behind but you know like so I mean
that's like my fantasy right like I
dream of taking Michael Jordan's final
game-winning shot but but let's just say
the heavens open and Ames will descend
it and said hey I'm gonna put you in
that situation right now well that's
gonna be pretty embarrassing right I'm
gonna be on the map I'm gonna be famous
for being the dorky guy that goofed it
up so just because you're in the right
circumstance doesn't mean you're
optimized for that circumstance but we
often orient the pursuit of meaning and
fulfillment around trying to procure the
right circumstance but the pearl of
great price is being the kind of the
right kind of person
it's pursuing experiences that help you
become a better version of yourself
because who cares if you get what you
want if you don't know how to be happy
with it
who cares if you get positioned where
you have a good opportunity if you don't
know how to capitalize on the
opportunity yeah and you don't have to
have great circumstances in order to
make choices that lead to that kind of
thing so do things that interest you
that fire you up because that's the
stuff that develops a sense of humor it
develops wisdom it develops
philosophical perspective and when you
have that those kinds of tools then the
world becomes more of a set of
ingredients that you can creatively
assemble into something it is that you
like and you have the skill set to do so
as well instead of just showing up to
the kitchen and never Beck's My partner
whom you met she had a roommate in
college who asked her hey can you help
me make this macaroni and cheese and
like she realized like she had been sort
of cobbled by very rich parents
throughout her entire upbringing and
she's like okay well first thing I do
the big boil the water and she said okay
how do I do that and realizing that you
can have all the ingredients there but
if you can't boil the water then you're
gonna starve to death
creatively intellectually spiritually
manat going to if you don't have the
skills to use those ingredients and the
ingredients themselves are useless
you're gonna be chewing on some stale
macaroni should I I'd love to send you
well it sounds to me like you need to
redefine what success is for you right
now
and that is not an easy thing to do and
I think I think success is perspectival
I think it's highly individual one man's
success is another man's failure and we
have an entire chapter about success in
our book essential there are the twelve
areas of living an intentional life and
one of those is trying to find out how
do you redefine success essential is a
book with 150 essays and it's an essay
collection that Ryan and I rode over the
course of five or six years where we we
talk about these twelve different areas
from minimalism to stuff to mindfulness
to success and everything in between
I'd love to send you a copy of that on
audiobook or Shawn if she wants the book
book or ebook please send her one of
those we love to hear what you have to
say so if you have a comment or tip
about goals or success or direction then
or including advice for any of our
callers today you can give us a call for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine leave us a voicemail there or you
can also send a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm where our favorite comments and
tips on a future episode and stay tuned
to the end of this episode we'll air
some comments and tips from previous
episodes Ryan you know what time it is
you know what time it is it is time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media yes indeed
we're on Twitter Facebook and Instagram
at the minimalists during the lightning
round this were Ryan and I and now TK
we'll all do our best to answer every
question which is the short shareable
less than 140 character response we also
put the text to these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our quotes in one place
minimal maxims dot-com all right our
first question is from Natalie I am very
I am a very motivated person however
even though I have some interesting
business ideas that would benefit my
career in dancing I cannot get the
motivation to just do it instead of
planning it what motivates you to work
especially if you're passionate about it
well my short answer is passion is
one-half love and one-half obsession and
really what I mean by that is I think of
writing like if people ask me like what
your passion for me like that that is
the the thing that I'm most passionate
about is writing but it is true drudgery
most of the time I teach a writing class
now and and one the one of the things I
try to convey is I when you first start
writing it's 90 percent drudgery 10
percent sort of pay off and it changes
over time as 80/20 70/30 eventually I
think you get to a point where it's
about 50/50 but even now even though I
write pretty much every day it's still
50/50 there are good days and there are
bad days and the bad days I still want
to put my head through the wall but on
the good days I'm thankful for those bad
days some of the best writing days
aren't days where I wrote two thousand
words or five thousand words there days
when I wrote negative four thousand
words and I just did a lot of editing
and deleting but I couldn't have done
that without all the drudgery of is
getting the the composition side of
things getting it on to the paper right
and so for me I love doing it but I also
I love the result but but I also I get
obsessed about it I'm willing to dive
deep in obsession is is about going deep
on something for long sustained periods
of time the other pithy answer I have
here is perspiration Trump's aspiration
that was my problem for a long time I
was an aspiring writer but I just
aspired all over myself and didn't
didn't do any of the work right and so
so I would say it sounds to me like
Natalie needs to find the the leverage
to obsess over it
I mentioned Derek severs a moment ago
and he basically and his book talks
about the value of ideas being low but
the value of action being really high
and the last thing I'll say is is
accountability partners they're just
having people in your life will help
hold you accountable I woke up this
morning really tired and if it was just
me recording this podcast I would have
cancelled it on myself but I have other
people who I'm accountable to right TK's
gonna be here Ryan's gonna be here
Shawn's gonna be here reschedule with
all of them and Ryan's leaving the Marla
I know like okay I need to show up and
do this and having someone here to help
hold me accountable is is helpful all
right my pet the answer is an idea is
worth nothing without action and TK I
did not know
that the root of passion it was to
suffer and when we say let's hope I'm
right about that so let's let's say I
mean that has literally changed how I
look how I look at the word passion now
because when someone says I'm really
passionate about X well now I'm gonna
ask well what kind of suffering have you
been through yeah to make that happen
when you're sand passion about something
I'm willing to suffer for I'm willing to
suffer through the drudgery of riding to
have written so so Natalie you know when
I when I look at her question what I
really hear her saying is I love to
daydream I really love the dream some
really big ideas and I just don't have
the motivation to to do it and again an
idea without action is nothing but the
question is is Natalie what are you
willing to suffer through to make those
ideas come to fruition sitting around
and daydreaming we all do that we all
love to do that man like I know I'll get
a really good idea and I'll call Josh oh
man I got this really really good idea
and I haven't done this in a while but I
used to do this a lot and Josh would be
like okay great um let's look at what we
have on our plate right now
how are we gonna be able to fit this
into what we already have and when I
started looking at it that way well I
call you less and less now hmm because I
know that an idea without action is
nothing yeah so so I guess you know the
the advice I want to give the natalie is
you find that leverage that at least
helps you take that first step if there
isn't a barrier in the way I mean if
it's fear of success or whatever it may
be I mean I think it's important to
recognize those fears but she has to
find some sort of leverage to at least
take the the first step towards bringing
one of these ideas to fruition yeah yeah
I think that's the key so my take on
this is if you're passionate about
something and you can't motivate
yourself to take that first step then
your first step is probably too big and
you need to reduce the size of that
passion is a very interesting thing
because when we say we're passionate
about something that concept tends to be
bundled up with other assumptions about
how
a person would behave if they were truly
passionate so for instance you hear
people say things like well I think I
love writing but I guess if I really
loved it I would write every day and
since I don't actually write every day I
guess I don't love it right or I think I
love running but I mean you know people
who really love it they run 5 miles a
day and I haven't ran all week so
therefore even though my heart is
telling me that I love it I will
logically deduce the conclusion that I
must not love what my heart is telling
me that I love and so we get confused
right because we have assumptions about
what a passionate person would do and
then we have like the visceral
experience of being passionate those two
things are bundled and it muddies our
thinking about it and you got to sort
those two things out and you got to say
okay wait a minute if I'm passionate
about something and I can't motivate
myself to act on it then that probably
means whatever my version of acting on
it is is bundled up with these
assumptions that need to be discarded so
if you're passionate about running and
you can't motivate yourself to run then
ask yourself well what does running look
like right now you know and now that may
be well running five miles a day right
I'm you know like you know running it's
like okay so back away from that and
make it ridiculously easy to start yeah
how does it feel to run for one block a
day well that seems like something I can
do get out there and do that but you
know what stops us from doing that the
two greatest motivation killers
obligation and guilt you're motivated to
do something already
but then obligation comes in on one side
and say it says yeah but if you were
really motivated you would do it 10
times more and then guilt comes in and
says yeah I know you say you're
motivated but you only did a little bit
and your passion is worthy of so much
more therefore your passion isn't really
there and you got to kill those things
so an example in my own life I'm
passionate about reading I love it more
than anything else but I went for about
six months in my life not reading
because I was just so busy and I didn't
have time to read books and you know
what the the breakthrough us for me is
when I said you know what I'm just gonna
read one blog post a day and I'm gonna
commit to that no matter what and you
know what not only have I read every day
but I've had many days where I felt like
crying because I feel like I am
insulting this thing I love because I'm
only read I'm not a real reader I don't
love reading because if I did I would
make time like all of those people who
write articles about how Warren Buffett
read 17 books a week right
and that's how we kill ourselves with it
man but but you got to make it
ridiculously easy to start and be loyal
to your passion in the way that you can
be get rid of the obligation and the
guilt dude that is so good well it makes
me think of that Rachel Cruz book that
I'm going through right now you know
what love your life not theirs yeah and
um she just does a great job in the
first chapter of just showing how
comparisons will kill us it will it will
really take away from our life if we sit
there and try to compare ourselves to
yeah we want to be a writer so let's
look at how my favorite writer writes
and what they've done oh I'm not
anywhere near that so I guess I'll never
be a writer like yeah I could be
developing because it's like you're my
favorite writers David Foster Wallace
but I also know I'll never write
Infinite Jest and if that was my slot my
expectation hmm then I would just well
just give up right now in fact most
people can't even read Infinite Jest let
alone write the book right but instead
if I say wow if my standard if I maybe I
can one day craft a sentence that is
like David Foster Wallace and then I try
to do that
you mean a 400 word sentence no I mean
that's also true I mean I have where
there's an 835 word sentence and
everything that remains but that was
also intentional right it was a shift in
the book and like it's supposed to be
this outloud thing but anyway I'm
getting too far away from that but
basically what I realized like there are
these there's there's this beauty yes I
don't have to have the the the
expectation we're gonna write Infinite
Jest but maybe I can write a sentence
that that is beautiful I love that man I
mean even thinking about like Hemingway
who's a great writer yeah what is it
little shoes for sale never worn like
the shortest story baby shoes for sale
number one right so even that is
something so simple which is genius it's
like you can just take that little bit
be like alright can I make a six word
story that is you know just as it just
starting with something really really
small because the drains breed
creativity we're talking about is some
constraints I mean I think Hemingway was
radically overrated but I'm just saying
that
loves the ruffle feathers no I actually
I don't think I think him it was a very
talented author and writer and I just
like III like messing with the people I
care about most yeah Nathalie I believe
was her name I kept saying Natalie but
it's Natalie oh I thought it was just a
weird spelling for Natalie it could be
either way Natalie or Natalie um I want
one thing before TK finishes up this
question so we can move on my micro
species simple triggers is an essay I
wrote we'll put a link to on the website
I do 60 pull-ups a minimum every single
day and the only reason I do that is not
because I have a goal every day to do 60
pull-ups because to me that's daunting
even now I think about them light and I
even though I do it every day I'm like
to do 60 pull-ups or run 5 miles
whatever it might be that's not that
sounds daunting but I know that I walk
below my the door between my bedroom my
bathroom at least 10 times and every
time I walk below there I do 6 pull-ups
and before I will go to the bathroom
with six quick pull-ups I'm done I walk
back out six pull-ups you know I do that
minimum 10 times a day quite often it's
a lot more than that right and so if not
just drink more water or forced me to go
to the bathroom more frequently and I
have these simple triggers so so maybe
the other answer for Nathalie here is is
what are your triggers so you want to do
these things you say you're very
motivated but but one of the triggers
that are going to take that motivation
and turn it into action mmm you know I
just wanted to offer this brief word of
encouragement and say at the end of the
day you can trust your own knowledge of
what it is you're interested in you know
Terence Mckenna refers to this as the
felt presence of immediate experience
the knowledge of what's fascinating to
you is not mediated knowledge it's not
inferred knowledge you know it at the
level of visceral experience and you got
to trust that and you can't get inside
your own head with you know fallacies
like if I were really interested in the
thing my heart is telling me I'm
interested in I would be excited 24
hours a day I would be motivated to
sacrifice my very life for it I would be
talking about it all the time I would
already have a book printed I would
already have three businesses built
forget all of that you
your passion is your passion and your
path for carving out a life where you
can devote yourself to your passion is
yours as well and it's unique to you
alright our next question is from Sarah
how do you find a new direction when you
realize you're going the wrong way
well I alluded to in that essay I wrote
I just reworded this but it's to make it
pithy
you won't see the Sun Rise if you're
facing westward and I think that that
ultimately you you realize all you have
to do is turn around we were talking
about walking away and walking towards
something I think it's important to know
what you're walking away from but it's
far more important to know what you're
walking toward and that's actually what
gives you the motivation which gives you
the leverage to move in that direction
and by the way it doesn't require the
full sprint in the opposite direction
that's going to wear you out yeah it's
just turning around yes all that it
takes yeah man I mean think about well
let's say much more answer first it's
wise to stop and get a lay of the land
before you change course so thinking
about going into direction with my car
if I realize I'm going down you know
Hollywood Boulevard and all of a sudden
I realize like I am going the wrong way
and let's say I'm in a hurry right like
so you know I'm speeding a little bit oh
no I'm going the wrong way
do I just take my wheel and crank it and
just do a u-turn right in the middle of
the street close your eyes well maybe
maybe in LA you do that but most places
you wouldn't just do that but but yeah
right close your eyes and hope for the
best and I think when people are going a
certain direction they are running
towards that direction and they're
putting everything they have into it and
all of a sudden they realize like oh
crap this is the wrong way and because
they have all this momentum built up
they feel like they need to just like
shift all that momentum somewhere else
but sometimes you just got to stop you
got to make sure there's no cars coming
behind ya find a nice spot to do a
u-turn and then you know start traveling
in a different direction so again this
is just my way of saying Sarah you don't
have to you don't have to take all that
momentum and keep it going it's okay to
slow down take a breath
and figure out what direction it is that
you need to go yeah so I think about
this quote by Michael Carr that says
it's hard to imagine the freedom we find
from the things we
behind I think one of the most difficult
aspects of you know choosing to quit
doing something that we know is hurting
us or hurting people in our lives or
leading us down a bad path is that we're
highly conscious of what we got to stop
doing I got to stop eating all this
refined sugar right but we're not
conscious of the freedom that we gain
from pursuing a new path so it's not
just about hey stop think you know stop
focusing on the negative and start
focusing on what you're going to do but
also focus on the freedom that you're
going to gain from what it is you do
like the whole idea behind minimalism is
that you minimalize to maximize that
that you know like spaces like this
invisible container that houses all the
things that of life and when you you
know like we can't see space because
it's filled up with things but when you
get rid of stuff you open up room for
space right and you and space moves from
the background hidden by all of this
stuff to the forefront and it becomes an
environment for play an environment for
the expression of freedom and the same
is true with bad habits the same is true
with moving in the inner and the
negative direction when you let those
things go you're getting rid of the
stuff that's holding you down and now
you're freeing up space in your life for
the emergence of creative ideas for the
emergence of new forms of play and that
is a form of freedom that is so much
better than having the answer to so
what's going to come next so focus on
that freedom not just on what you're
going to give up because giving giving
something up that isn't good for you is
not without its reward ever yeah just
recently they said something about the
cost of your new life is your old life
and I think part of that is true but but
it's really understanding what you're
getting for that cause it's just not
giving up something no one just wants to
give the people don't people hate change
they hate being changed even more and so
when you were walking away from this
this old life you're also walking yeah
you're walking away from some of the
good things you said talk about giving
up refined sugar or whatever like you're
walking away from that flavor but you're
also walking away from all the negative
effects of that so you can walk toward
whatever this this new thing is we got
one more question here and that is from
Lau Lau says my tendency is to have
multiple goals / directions what do you
do when you have too many goals and they
all bring value to you do you multitask
or you focus on one goal and then move
on to the next so if you like to hear
our answers to that question you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
over at the minimalist private podcast
available exclusively to our patreon
supporters that's why it's a private
podcast so if you want to support our
show and if you want to help keep this
podcast 100% advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to the
PostScript episodes every week
the minimalist private podcast feed
includes our monthly ask the minimalist
anything episodes unreleased recordings
of our live events we just put out
Sydney and Melbourne and we've got
Detroit and Tampa and a bunch of others
out there as well and the entire back
catalog of past private episodes so if
you become a supporter you get that
whole back catalogue of over 50 private
podcast episodes and once you become a
supporter you also receive a personal
link to our private podcast feeds so
that it plays in whatever podcast app
you're using right now so if you listen
to this on Apple podcast or feedly or
overcast or whatever this will show up
the private podcast will show up right
there you don't have to get onto some
web page in your computer to listen to
it and as a patreon supporter you also
receive access to our monthly livestream
videos as well as first access to
tickets to all of our live events before
those tickets are available to the
general public you can find all the
details and all the good stuff over at
the minimalists comm slash support and
here is a snippet from this week's
PostScript episode
[Music]
the thought of living a life with no
goals sounded insane to me
it was counterintuitive it was scary and
it went against everything I had learned
about productivity in my corporate life
of yesterday year I managed hundreds of
people for a large corporation an
organization which I was considered the
productivity guy the gold guy I met
deadlines I overproduced I exceeded
expectations I got results that's why
they pay me the big bucks right I
regularly had umpteen goals in various
stages of completion short-term goals
long-term goals personal goals business
goals health goals financial goals
vacation goals consumer purchasing goals
you name it I thought if I crossed
enough goals off my to-do list I'd
eventually be content alright we're back
if you want to hear that full
conversation you can become a patron
over at the minimalists com okay now
it's time for our added value portion of
the shows where Ryan and I let's talk
about some of those added value to our
lives recently Ryan I know was a week or
two ago I mentioned push a tease new
album because I mean it's total
juvenilia but it's really well packaged
juvenilia and he seems to not be able to
talk about things that he didn't talk
about at age 19 but and I was hoping to
come in this week and talk about Kanye's
album which is like every song isn't up
for you right now isn't it it's offset
all seven were top seven yeah yeah all
seven his song for the top seven song
but it seems like a really beautiful
unfinished thought is the way I would
describe it so I'm not gonna that's not
really adding value to my life I listen
to it a couple times and then I let it
go and then he and Kid Cudi put out an
album this week and it sounded like
elevator music in a really sheshe Hotel
the like remember they they put up some
of this really nice hotel when we were
in Australia we were in Melbourne oh
yeah and they put us in this like really
like too cool for school hotel yeah I
feel like this album should have been
playing on that elevator okay so I can't
recommend that either but um I do in a
wreck
Tim Ferriss did a podcast episode with
Terry Crews a few months back you
probably know Terry Crews yes bus guy
yeah exactly
Brooklyn nine-nine it was this heartfelt
conversation about finding success and
failure and failure and success in
territories is one of the most
vulnerable people oh my god
it was one of the best it's probably the
best Tim Ferriss podcast episode I've
ever heard and I don't say that lightly
because I think he's done a bunch of
really good conversations with people
but he was so vulnerable and for such a
strong man to be so vulnerable but but
not weak it was it shows you that that
weak and vulnerable are not sending them
the fact boner ability can be a synonym
with strength when we when we use it to
our Vantage so yeah we'll put a link to
that in the show notes Ryan what's been
added value to your life man I think we
might have recommended this already but
I'm gonna rear ekam end it because it's
it's very apropos to this podcast
Rachael Cruz is already mentioned in
earlier love your life not theirs it's
just what I love about this book is a
like it really has helped me see how I
compare myself to others and I'd even
realize I was doing its unconscious yes
it's like it's these unconscious
comparisons that we have the other thing
too is like Rachael Cruz runs me of us
men like we are not out here saying I'd
be a boss with a good childhood yeah
exactly
but she reminds me of us in the sense
that you know we are not out here saying
we're the minimalists and here's how you
be a minimalist here's how you'd be the
perfect minimalist and maybe one day
maybe one day you can be like Josh and I
I mean that is not our approach at all
if anything we're just kind of like
fumbling our way through it and sharing
our lives with with our audience and
Rachael Cruz she just has such a good
job of you know not pointing the finger
and saying you need to do this you need
to do that you need to do this it's
about her own personal experiences with
these things that everyone struggles
with yeah and it's really relatable it's
a great book yeah I'm looking forward to
diving into that because we were got an
event coming up with her in Nashville
and so I want to be well-versed in her
book and she has another one called
smart money smart kids which is which is
also really helpful with you if you have
kids
and just starting to instill the just
the fundamentals of responsible money
management which was never given to me
when I was a kid starting that young I
mean Ellis five now she just turned five
and I'm already thinking about yeah
we're already going through like she's
understanding what the difference
between a five and a one dollar bill is
and like we're just trying to to go
through the the absolute basics right
now but but building that foundation so
she has a by the time she turns 18 she
doesn't say oh well now the right thing
to do is go on I don't know what I want
to do with my life so I should take on
$100,000 worth of debt right yeah so
yeah well I'll definitely dive in both
those books and we'll talk to her about
them we did that event with her at CK in
Nashville CK do you got a you got a
favorite album you're listening to right
now or a favor blog or a favorite book
if not no worries man we're kind of put
me on the spot yeah so do I go with have
I totally goes have I told you guys
about my Corky music thing
no no Oh hundreds of thousands of people
I heard I heard Coltrane and Davis so I
have no idea so I'm definitely a jazz
fan but I can you Utah Jazz all the way
I kid you not
365 days a year without exaggeration I
listen to Christmas music I love it dude
yeah it's not the only kind of music but
I listen to Christmas music all year
round why so the the surface answer is
that the the energy of Christmas music
is just pure it always feels good it's
you know put you in a good movement
yeah it's incorruptible man like and
there's my way of describing it any kind
of music you like technically I can take
it and put it in a horror movie and with
the right scene I can creep you out with
it right one two Freddy's coming for you
right it would seem like wow man that's
like a an innocent children's song and
you just creeped me out with it by
putting it in Nightmare on Elm Street
yeah Christmas music you cannot do that
it's incorruptible man and it's the only
form of music that is that way so if you
put on Santa Claus is coming to town
or you know winter wonderland in the
middle of April you'll just have a good
hat that's great advice like if you're
feeling down put on some Christmas music
dude I love it
I'm gonna try next time is there one is
there a Christmas album that we should
put in the show notes for anyone like a
best-of is it Michael Buble every time
[Laughter]
365 days a year listening William
Shatner's Christmas elf I'll give you
one song because I think this is too
much to ask gotta give him a whole album
just if you're gonna listen to one song
let's go with Johnny Mathis sleigh ride
all right see if you don't feel it all
right hey Sean can we take out the
podcast in the podcast today with Johnny
Mathis sleigh ride all right let's move
on to two right here right now so we
talked about what's going on the lives
of the minimal so we got a few things
going on the podcast we've got some some
guests coming on Ryan's gonna be gone
next week and I'm bringing in my doctor
well two of them actually from nourish
balance thrive so for those of you
who've been listening for a while you
know I've gone through a whole bunch of
health problems from seed if in my gut
which kills 14,000 people a year in the
United States to mercury poisoning to
the really bad back problems my hormones
were out of whack and I had a whole
bunch of other problems we're gonna get
really really detailed and intimate on
this and we're gonna talk about health
problems and what I've done what I've
done to work really hard to fix them
over the last two three years and so the
folks from nourish balance thrive will
be on next week and after that we're
gonna have Ryan Delk from Omni is gonna
be on the podcast so me is this company
who who they're only in a few cities
right now but I Ryan and I've been
talking about Ryan Nicodemus and I have
been talking about this for a while how
we're shifting from this culture of
ownership to a culture of access no
longer do I need to own the the
Christmas albums all on my shelf I don't
need to have a hundred of them I can
have them all in my pocket right so we
have access to them that's more
important than having ownership right
and now we're seeing that with the share
economy or what I would just call the
access economy like lyft and uber and
and we're seeing these technologies how
they're allowing us to own fewer things
but
access to more things I mean growing up
I didn't have to have a basketball court
in my backyard in order to play
basketball there was a park right down
the street and so I'd go to the park and
and play basketball there you didn't
have to have a pool in your backyard to
go swimming if there was a community
pool available or some sort of
membership that you could sign up for
and now this this company called Omni
they're trying to do that with our
everyday stuff and I want to dive deep
with him
Nicodemus will be back for that so we'll
talk to Ryan Delk about that as well in
a couple weeks so that's what's going on
with the podcast also every day we're
doing a living room conversation maybe
if we have enough time TK you can join
us for we'll do an off-site living room
conversation we're answering one simple
living question per day over on YouTube
you can find all of those over at
youtube.com slash the minimalist a lot
of really good questions have been
answered and obviously a lot of bad
questions too but we're not picking
those so we're picking the really good
questions and we're answering those and
Ryan you and I just did one yesterday
about how do you deal with criticism and
so we we do a bit of a deep dive on that
so living room conversations over on
YouTube also BAM you guys and Suzanne
questions like why is Michael Jordan the
greatest of all time well actually which
one of his many attributes makes them
the great I mean I think he's definitely
top five simply southern tour we're
headed we're headed down south we're
gonna be in Alabama and Kentucky and
Tennessee we're gonna be with Chris
Hogan and Rachel Cruz and Anthony O'Neal
we're gonna talk about money and
minimalism on the store so the whole
Dave Ramsey team is going to be with us
the minimalists calm slash tour for all
the details
looking forward to chatting with them on
stage at all three of those events and
oh and then I think that's this coming
weekend
this is coming out yeah this weekend I'm
gonna do my first and maybe even only
writing workshop of the year I tend to
do two a year so I might do one more
this year but I do a teach a four-week
writing class and in that writing class
we we go over a whole bunch of stuff
that I realized not everyone has the
money or the time to spend four weeks on
a writing class
so I do a two-hour live writing workshop
online it's called how to write better
and that's June 24th if you can't attend
a live event don't worry there'll be a
video available afterward and I do a Q&A
at the end so the only thing you'll miss
is the the Q&A at the end although
you'll get to see the recorded Q&A
called how to write better you can file
details of that over at the minimalists
comm slash workshop and if you want to
get all the show notes to these episodes
then just go to the minimalists com
enter your email address at the top
we'll never ever send you spam just to
show notes and of course any new essays
that we write those will go right to
your inbox and Ryan you got anything
else for us finally here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners - Ryan this is Jennifer in
Rochester New York I have two short
comments one is to Katrina who is on
podcast 43 she had a question about the
wedding gift I just wanted to remind
everybody that instead of asking for
experience gifts or not asking for gifts
you can also ask for donations to your
favorite charity my cousin did this at
her wedding and it was wonderful you
could leave a donation and you could
leave your name along with the donation
so they would know that you gifted for
them concerning your podcast with which
role I wanted to remind everyone about
the grocery store Aldi if it is in your
city please check it out they're having
a larger and larger assortment of
organic foods they have breast fed beef
you can purchase and it's very
affordable hello minimalist my name is
Malia and I live in Victorville which is
a small city in California I just wanted
to help everyone out there and let them
know that it you hate daily planners and
you feel like it's a clutter bug and you
don't like it and it's too restrictive
for you I would like to suggest a bullet
journal you can look it up on Pinterest
or online I find that Pinterest can free
them up creative but it helps you plan
out your day and use blank pages to your
best interests so I can write whatever I
want on any page and still plan out my
week my meals my grocery list
and it took everything that I want all
of the list all of the little notes
Olive you know speaking of so they keep
around my house it keeps them all in one
place and having one book for everything
because it's a blank page book and you
get to write it in not only
communicative accuse me organize the
member laughter he's trying to be more
intentional but you take a lot of notes
near the bullet journal hi this is
Brooke from New Brighton I was calling
in response to the latest podcast
episode 133 constraints I'm responding
to Derek's question about wanting to
travel more but filling constraints and
teachers custody of his daughter Josh
had mentioned on the podcast how he
found a school that was more flexible
with hours absences my suggestion for
Derek is to look into cyber charter
schools there are many cyber schools for
kindergarten through twelfth grade now
and that are either with any state or
with or a few that are countrywide I
think that is something worth looking
into and might provide him the
flexibility or opportunity to travel or
even take his daughter with him and that
case I actually work for a cyber school
in Pennsylvania and love it I think it
is a great option and it provides me
with flexibility and I never thought was
possible with a profession and teaching
but I also see the view as a teacher and
how it provides a lot of flexibility for
students and they have opportunity to
travel and do other things that
otherwise wouldn't be possible all right
Joe that's almost it for this episode
I want to thank TK for being here today
yeah man thanks guys we'll put a link to
your website TK Coleman comm also
discover praxis comm for folks who are
interested in that also your new podcast
season 2 of office hours is starting up
right now so you can go back catch up on
season 1 I highly recommend it with you
and Isaac and next time Isaac is in Los
Angeles tell him to come on out we'll
we'll get both you in here or just him
either way and he can help us answer
some questions check that out wherever
you get podcasts thank you so much for
being here with us man it's always a
pleasure yeah it's always fun thanks for
having me guys yeah
so all right Joe if you have a
a question for the minimalist you can
give us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also send
a voice memo right to your right right
right right right right right from your
phone then I think the record just
skipped right yeah man it looks like
podcasts and your programming had a bug
in it or something watching Westworld
they start freaking out a little bit the
robots are cutting down right from your
phone podcast to the venomous calm if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus
[Laughter]